somebody else that really is excited
about bitcoin is michael sailor
microstrategy this morning michael
sailor announced that microstrategy has
purchased an additional 1 434 bitcoins
for 82.4 million dollars in cash at an
average price of
hundred
57
seven dollars per bitcoin as of december
ninth of this year they hold one hundred
and twenty two thousand four hundred and
seventy eight bitcoin which they
acquired for three point six six billion
dollars at an average price of twenty
nine thousand eight hundred sixty one
861
per bitcoin michael saylor has very deep
conviction he just spent another 82
million dollars to go after it now the
key piece to this is one conviction is a
superpower people obviously like bitcoin
people hold bitcoin but there are very
few people in the world who continuously
to relentlessly acquire as much bitcoin
as possible michael saylor is pioneering
a public market strategy where he
continues to run his software business
but also has a treasury strategy to add
more and more bitcoin to it on top of
that one of the things that i find most
interesting is that even though he has
continued to purchase bitcoin in the 30
000 40 000 50 000 60 000
price points his average purchase price
is still sub 30 000 so he's up about 2x
he's spent over the last less than 18
months 3.66 billion dollars to acquire
those 122 000 bitcoin the more that
people like michael saylor continued to
display their conviction right they're
not using words only they are actually
looking at their actions you can see the
conviction i think that it will inspire
more and more people to do this we know
that there are other publicly traded
companies like tesla and square that
have already done it but we believe that
there will be many many other non-crypto
non-bitcoin type publicly traded
companies that will start to do this
over time and michael saylor is that
pioneer so it's pretty incredible to see
when you saw him tweet it out what was
the reaction on another 82 million for
the bitcoin john
wouldn't expect anything less from him
at this point right he has gone
completely into bitcoin he clearly sees
it as a store of value um
his he has different thoughts i think
around the global reserve currency
aspect of it and the medium of exchange
but he clearly sees bitcoin as the apex
predator asset with a fixed supply um i
love his conviction it's not surprising
they bought another 82 million dollars
seven million dollars a day uh during
this dip per se is pretty wild joe what
do you think not surprising whatsoever
when he was in here a few weeks ago uh
one of the things i specifically made
sure to ask was like how do you feel
about the price volatility like is this
something where you're checking because
you people got to remember right he's
losing hundreds of millions of dollars
on a like on on a mark to market basis
when bitcoin declines ten percent five
percent 15 20 whatever it is right but
he's losing or on a marked market basis
he is down a lot of money so i
specifically asked hey like how do you
think about that and his answer was just
so genuine and just like i don't think
about it at all right he's like yeah
obviously like there's some kind of
emotional aspect to it but like i don't
feel that at all like i just know for
sure he is so convicted that this is
going to be the asset of the future and
the greatest asset uh
of all time really i think is what he's
essentially saying and this is something
he's just trying to acquire as much as
he can at the lowest price possible so
when bitcoin dips and there's a 20
plunge in 24 hours like everyone should
have expected that he was doing this
yeah i am uh i'm surprised every time
even though we shouldn't be right
because it's like he just made the big
purchase and like dude he found another
82 million dollars right and i always
imagined him just like waking up one day
and getting like a email from the cfo
like oh we just found 82 million dollars
buy bitcoin right and then they just go
and they buy more so it makes